five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of genius brain podcast we got a
very special guest today that we're
actually gonna rerecord the beginning of
this because haha [ __ ] [ __ ]
I started this [ __ ] up and I didn't hit
record on the recorder as you can see we
don't have an engineer here so I got to
do it all by myself
that's what keeping an organic man okay
I'm keeping it real we have a longtime
friend here
I've known this do for about seven years
and also not an LA native no we came
here for the for the LA dream of of
seeking a job basically getting paid
somehow yeah yeah I've known for her
yeah about seven years but used to live
in k-town together you know I used to
live at this spot called the Tallmadge
tell montages a is a is a icon in LA
it's like this old retro not retrofitted
because it is it was made in the 1900s
yeah and we used to be in this apartment
called apartment 904 Club 904 Club 904
yeah and we shot a bunch of films and a
bunch of music videos there it's
actually a really popular spot for a lot
of people to go film like I think like
you saw like NCIS was there all the time
yeah yeah like second floor they would
take out like that whole unit then
didn't they get paid for leaving the
people who lived there or something
yeah people they they I guess like I'm
not actually sure but I know that they
used a few apartments there right I
think some people owned it they owned oh
we might have like owned that individual
floor oh unit there and they all
commented out or something I I have no
but it was was he pain in the ass though
right cuz yeah they shot like Wendy's
commercials there
oh yeah that's right I remember yeah
yeah it was it was an interesting
experience man that was the days of we
used to go drinking every night yeah
k-town yeah wakow Wakamatsu every day
pretty barbecue every day oh man he was
also a former fat man yeah still a
little chunky but uh you know getting
there getting there yeah I mean you were
doing your whole fitness thing for quite
a while yeah
I remember like you were getting on the
bigger side and yeah one day you were
just like I gotta change this about
myself
yeah definitely it was a it was a moment
it was a defining moment it was like
June of 2015
yeah or something keep continue keep
going yeah it was pretty crazy 2015 you
know I just decided man like it's time
to be a man you know it's time to really
just stick to your these decisions that
you make is like for years I've been
always like you know yeah I'm gonna get
in shape you know whether it's a New
Year's resolution or it'd just be a
random moment of the year you know I
felt like I had always failed myself so
in this particular time you know that
was a defining moment I'm gonna do it
right now you did some hardcore macro
dining oh my gosh
bro I I remember when you asked me about
macro - yeah yeah I mean I got all my
info from you like if you guys don't
know dave is like a huge resource for
for all things health and fitness I just
never play no but you know but that's so
interesting too because I feel like you
know it's same thing with like
relationship advice right I feel like we
have this ability to provide like
excellent perspective yeah in an opinion
on certain things especially when we're
not involved in that specific
relationship yeah right that outside
perspective and a lot of times like
people who might not look like they are
like a wealth of help in terms of
fitness and health and you know dieting
and stuff but there's a lot of
information that we take it you know it
doesn't mean that you're less
knowledgeable only because you haven't
applied it yourself
yeah so I mean for you when you when you
lost that way yeah because I'm pretty
sure you tried losing weight before yeah
yeah it didn't work my gosh I you know
that's the interesting thing too because
a lot of people ask that well how did
you lose the weight right well how do I
start dude because right the the journey
started like ten years ago yeah you know
and it's not like I said you might my
new year's goal was to lose like thirty
pounds for the past ten years right yeah
people don't see that yeah yeah oh so
you lost the weight yo you did it it was
like how did you do it it's not
yes it there is somewhat of a formula to
it yeah
but the journey to get there is very
very hard yeah and I I always tell
people to and maybe I'll ask you this
too when when they say well how did you
lose the weight and the first thing I
tell them - it's like number one I have
to get it in my head that at first it's
not going to be easy
yeah it's going to be a journey and
time-consuming yes right I am consuming
it definitely because we didn't have the
habit right right right so we whatever
we thought was normal
wasn't normal right you know my friend
said it the best he goes you know what
do when you eat [ __ ] food if you have
diarrhea every day that's just called
poop diarrhea every day and I'm like yo
yeah that's just poop baby let me just
I'm just gonna go poo yeah yeah yeah
imma you know I'm talking to my friends
I'm like yo how was your poop yeah just
casually I feel like solid I'm like your
poop is solid son must be nice bright it
was just net you know I started getting
like sleep apnea yeah that's right I
remember yeah I couldn't breathe when I
was that better now Oh a hundred percent
okay like I still snore but I'm not
cheating on my right right right
you know yeah that [ __ ] is dangerous no
like a people died from it yeah that's
crazy man and you know there's there's
things that you can't deny yeah and I
think a lot of the times the the
physical pain and the discomfort that
we're dealing with yeah becomes
normalized to us yeah and so for us it's
normal normal exactly so when people ask
hey how are you feeling yeah we always
say okay yeah because knee pain joint
pain back pain
heavy breathing another day right it's
just a normal day right right and then
when you know you start having
conversations with people who are fit
yeah and they don't feel those type of
things and then I started become a
highly just it just became more apparent
right you know especially now because
I'm 30 now yeah and then I started
feeling knee pain the [ __ ] is this
right right this [ __ ] I used to make fun
of old people about yeah right but
you're the one now that's the butt of
the jokes bro I didn't even know I was
fat dude I didn't know none of you
[ __ ] [ __ ] told me I was walking
around thinking I was perfectly fine
dude brother Loki we were like we were
encouraging you to come work out with us
you would but I I didn't need it because
I wasn't a fat person right I was like
were you why you keep telling you to
work out bro I'm not fat
what are you saying man
I'm gonna I'm an Olympic athlete right
like I would walk around and arguably I
always say this [ __ ] - there was his
timer I remember I was having lunch with
Muriel right and I was sitting down and
I go and there we were eating I think it
was like Korean barbecue or something I
can't remember what the meal was let's
just say I was Korean barbecue for story
saying and there was two people sitting
across from us yeah they were huge I
looked at them and I was like Muriel
dude if I ever get that fat just [ __ ]
kill me look at those fat yeah yeah she
looked me dead into the windows of my
soul she goes you're fatter than them oh
no like what what do you talk about me
yes because you're fat yeah clearly
she's on her period I don't know what's
going on but I am NOT a fat person right
right you know but you start to like
blame everything else around you right
yeah they don't make exhales like they
used to it right right no [ __ ] they may
or psi yeah this [ __ ] European cut
make sure did like no it's like no bro
you're [ __ ] fat you fat [ __ ] yeah you
know what's interesting for me is like
growing up in Sweden I would say I would
argue that the ratio of like bigger
people is smaller like the amount of
people that are bigger like usually I
remember as a kid we will kind of laugh
at like us sizes actually sidenote my
first u.s. trip ever in my life I came
to New York City yeah we went to Macy's
with my mom and it was like a hallelujah
moment cuz she finally found pants sizes
that would fit me oh you know because
like they didn't carry those pants sizes
for kids in Sweden at the time yeah but
when we came to the u.s. it's just kind
of so you were a fat kid - I was fat
since I was born like like you just kept
baby weight consistently yeah you know
people say oh no you'll lose it by the
time you hit like they're not I did not
punch them wrong yeah I was the anomaly
I was the outlier and I actually added
on to that and working at McDonald's
didn't help but that's a story for a
different you did work everything else
dude you had a [ __ ] fro - bro I had a
biggest fro it didn't fit the hairnet I
had to roll it up into a bun
shoving in the back of the hat but yeah
did you did you when you were younger
did you feel self-conscious about being
fat definitely yeah hell yeah
everywhere I went like I hate PE I hate
going to the pool and all that stuff
taking off your shirt yeah you know I
remember as a kid going to the pool
because my mom forced me to go swimming
Asian mom right yeah there were a few
sports that she forced me to go you know
I tend trying to or thinking that it
would help me lose weight yeah but she
motivated me with McDonald's like well
well I'll take you to McDonald's a few
what was the source dude she literally
she planted that McDonald's see she's my
baby Jew with a double cheeseburger
everyday so like if you work give you
this cheeseburger yeah yeah how does
that work out I don't know but she's
just like you know you just got to go
move yeah yeah yeah but either way I
remember going to the pool and I always
have to wear a shirt like I never would
walk around and just could never take it
I couldn't I would only take it off when
I was gonna hop in the pool but that was
like okay split second like I'm gonna
take it off I'm a hop in right yeah I
get out the pool wipe myself down put on
my shirt yeah maybe cuz you know I was I
was I was ashamed like cuz I was
different from the other kids there yeah
and also not only being the like the
fattest kid around but also the only
Asian kid oh that's right so we had to
kind of deal with with both of those
worlds like people looking at you
because you're the Chinese kid and also
they're the fat Chinese kid yeah exactly
I was I was the fat asian kid damn you
know that's so interesting mit like I
felt like in high school if I'm gonna be
real yeah you know I I dealt with my me
being overweight with humor mmm you know
so I would always crack jokes and yeah a
lot of it would be self-deprecating
humor yeah which I learned from stand-up
comics right they would do
self-deprecating humor and they would
take that negativity and turn it into
laughter right right well at a certain
point like for me that started becoming
a part of my identity
like I can't be David unless I'm fat
David mm-hmm because I learned to take
that negativity into a positivity right
and you know that was like my stick that
was my spiel ya know and that was who
you were that was who I was and I was
completely okay with it right because I
would still play ball I was still active
play football do whatever you know when
I was in 20 I started taking kickboxing
to even a bigger guy but even but that's
a different
yeah I tried losing weight at that point
right it's right now right but in high
school I wasn't as big as I got when I
was older but I will still consider fat
that day yeah I remember during like our
senior picnic or whatever we would go to
Folsom Lake and swim yeah and when we
would go swim in high school even though
I said I was okay with being a bigger
person right and whether this is because
of other people making fun of me because
I was fat yeah or whether I didn't like
the way that I looked it could have been
a combination of both yeah but we when
we would go to Folsom Lake mm-hmm I
would swim mmm with my shirt on oh man
so I wouldn't take my shirt off just to
hide cuz I felt like a lot of the big
people did that and I'm like oh yeah you
know I don't if I look back on it now I
wasn't comfortable with my weight right
not like how I was when I got older when
I got older I got even fatter yeah but I
became too comfortable with it right
right when I was in Hawaii um like
Hawaii Hawaiians there are some big
people yeah they go swimming without
their shirt and I think that's what I
loved about Hawaii yeah the most was
that people don't give a [ __ ] right out
there just to have fun and relax if
you're the person right in the world who
the [ __ ] cares have fun in the water
yeah and I you know when I started going
into my 20s I'm like you know what [ __ ]
it dude it's not like if I don't wear
this teacher people don't know I'm fat
Ryan it's not the [ __ ] cloak from
Harry Potter like [ __ ] if you wear the
t-shirt they still know you're fat David
Wright doesn't change right right and
that's what I had to learn how to be
okay with you so the mentality of loving
myself yeah came first yeah and then I
lost the weight rafter right so I had to
learn how to separate those two out yeah
and that's what I'm talking about it was
a whole journey yeah you know yeah it's
a journey of self-discovery like you
really have to find out what the reasons
for you doing it is cuz it is I mean I I
would argue that genetics hat plays a
part in it like yeah if I have a hundred
percent madoka leave dude yeah that is
Jack beyond belief
we could have the same exact diet and he
would still be jacked a hundred percent
we blow up
I see no pizza Snickers Twizzlers fruit
roll-ups and then he somehow gained six
pounds of mussels dude like it's the
most annoying thing on earth dude like
those guts
must be nice Kay yeah he's just a nice
Special K dude that's what I call them
Special K okay
you know and I think did you ever feel
like I remember when you were so you you
did macro dieting right I didn't and
then I introduced that macro dining yeah
at the time yeah when I was using it and
it ranked out yeah later on I found out
for myself and then macro dieting didn't
work as well to a certain extent sure
yeah macro dine does work yeah it's
science it's not the end-all be-all yeah
yeah it's science for I think for people
who can follow instruction very well
yeah
macro dining works that's right I mean
there there's more to it than just put
it plugging in those numbers yeah to
being healthy in terms of like like
micro nutrition you know making sure
that you you vary your diet whatever
there's a whole other thing to it right
right but if you start with macro
dieting for people who just want to
follow something step-by-step it's going
to work
oh you definitely without fail
definitely yeah cuz it's science yeah
scientific 100% so this time during your
diet I guess like I remember so you you
you went through phases you went you
were fat see yeah then you went from
really skinny yeah and then you was from
skinny z22 more meat powerlifting yeah
lifting heavy weights right so what made
you want to switch because I felt like
the first first time you lost weight you
know you went for the aesthetic and
after that you went for strength yeah
well I just wanted to it became like a
challenge you know yeah big this journey
started out with just wanting to be
healthier yeah and in a certain extent
one of the reasons why I got so into it
because I saw I treated it as like a
part and extension of my my job yeah as
being an aspiring artist so being an
artist oh because of the music yeah
because of the music you know it was
like you know especially because that
was one thing that I heard I remember
like around ten years ago I was doing
showcases for labels right yeah a lot of
times were like hey you know you sound
great you have a great voice music is
great but you look like a Chinese chef
first of all yeah like how do we market
you you know you are gonna be doing RMB
you're gonna be up against the Neos of
the world the Usher's of the world right
they are they have an aesthetic to them
yeah so how are you gonna compete I feel
like that has changed today it's because
of that indie label marketing right yeah
like you know everybody's doing their
own thing you could choose your own path
I don't need the record label right you
have stuff like what's it called Spotify
right it started off with like what is a
band camp or SoundCloud SoundCloud you
got the SoundCloud and crowd now you
write so like a lot of these people were
popping up without having somebody be
the gateway that says hey you can't come
right exactly you know yeah
but I see I'm kind of old school still
like that where I came up or had my
formative years in that era of course
you want that record deal right what was
the feeling to that well I don't I I
used to yes maybe not so much now cuz I
know like you know the power of being
able to do it yourself yeah but like ten
years ago that was that was the only way
yeah you know so having been in that era
in just getting that and that concept
and thought and grain into my mind like
hey you gotta there are certain
expectations you have to fulfill to be
able to be eligible for a career like
yes right so that was I took that and
use that as a fuel like hey if you're
gonna if you're gonna quote unquote make
it you have to look a certain way which
is absolutely not true anymore
yeah but I use that to my advantage and
I mean ten years ago I would say that
was true oh yeah 100% for sure you know
because no matter what art that you go
into yeah there's there's work beyond
the art oh yeah and for sure a lot of
people don't understand that no they
don't you know they don't understand
that okay so it's cool you made music
right right that's dope yeah how are you
gonna get it out there right it's this
whole other ballgame when it comes on
yeah no matter what you do whether it's
acting whether it's music whether it's
anything else it's like people don't
know how important and how far
relationships going oh yeah and for me
it's it's a I like it and I dislike it
right because it's like how come I can't
just create how people love it and just
be at the end of the right right so
people don't understand like okay well
how come this person as an actor got
this deal and you didn't yeah well they
have the relationships and I don't yeah
a lot of the times it's not even about
talent sometimes right and it's not it's
about its marketability and just like
timing and just all these other factors
that are involved yeah I mean for you to
like you know cuz you stopped doing
music yeah for for a bit yeah
disappeared what was the biggest reason
you know I just think I needed to spend
some time to really just find my
artistic identity you know it's hard it
is hard yeah it's so hard finding your
sound is alright gosh
it's not only about sound it's about
because you know people tend to enjoy or
just experience the end product know the
things that you've made right once
you're done and finish but people don't
usually see everything that happens
leading up to it yeah or the the
inception of it or the creation of it
cuz you know and I'm sure it's with like
any kind of creative craft or writing
like you can't just in your schedule
like pen out Oh from 5 to 10 p.m. I'm
just gonna sit and crank this out yeah
you know it's like it's it's something
you're manifesting from thin air yeah
you know and it's got to be coherent and
consistent on this so there's a lot of
factors that are in play that that you
know people might not be privy to yeah
so for me I took this last year off
basically just really trying to find out
who I am as an artist like what do i
what do i what do I sound like Who am I
yeah so I'm getting there I don't think
I'm there fully yet but uh so have you
have you moved on past you know just
doing covers and I always say that
because like I like I see a lot of
YouTube musicians right that are cover
artists they don't even know that
they're a cover artist right right
meaning that they don't actually know
music just know how to sing the words
that somebody else wrote without even
putting their own input taste or style
to it
right right right they say I'm a
musician writes like you know that's
cool anybody can put a label to them
right yeah but if I put you in a studio
and a booth yeah right alright if I put
you in a writing session with somebody
or even beyond that let's say you're not
even you're a Justin Bieber right right
we don't really create the art right you
can manifest somebody else's or smash it
sure could you do that right and I feel
like a lot of these artists can't and
it's hard because and I'm not knocking
on YouTube musicians but there's a lot
of people who say that there are
musicians on YouTube who can't do any of
that [ __ ] and they carry that label with
such pride and it's like for me it's I
want to say it's
they're not really [ __ ] on the craft
but I think for them what might help
them out is to really focus on that it's
like if you're a musician are you doing
that work right you know can you
actually create music because when you
keep doing these covers and you don't
add your own even if you don't add your
own flair to it you're not creating
original music right
you're not gonna develop your artistry
at all right right and it comes out when
you see these cats they do their
original music and it sounds terrible
you know I think it comes back to like
the question of what why are you doing
this in the first place yeah you know
like what is it that you're trying to
gain out of this right yeah for me
personally I I can only speak for myself
but like when I recreate something be it
a cover like I don't just do it verbatim
like you know there has to be an element
of me in there yeah I have to be able to
when I hear a song be like okay I'm
envisioning it I can hear it in this way
and I think that would be really cool so
I think the question that that I always
ask myself is how am i contributing to
the cultural landscape
ya know of things like if I do if I
choose to do this song be it an original
or a cover right like how is this gonna
add to the landscape of color that
exists out there yeah and I think
sometimes people like you know I'm not
gonna speak for others motivations but
it could be purely monetary you know it
could be purely for likes and views and
you get like a gratification through
that which is fine you know if that's
your if that's your thing go for it
right but I feel like if if there is any
creative like bone in an artist be it
music or whatever else like you wanna
push yourself you know you want to
explore how you can manifest your
identity and your experiences into
whatever format that it is that you're
choosing you know it's it's just that
artists expression and yeah you know we
we've we've touched on this before where
it's if somebody isn't what is it left
brain is that the artists side is the
left brain or something yeah I think so
yeah let's just let's just say this is
right there's gonna be the right but
yeah I say left brain right whatever um
it's hard to tell somebody who's not in
that area how to understand how we feel
about certain things right right
so like you guys remember right
something called carpool confessions and
this essentially was a carpool podcast
beloved it yeah it was it was
entertaining it was funny and it was
getting great views and it was making my
channel a decent amount of money and
when I got done with it I was done with
it yeah
and people are like you'll bring it back
why aren't you doing it anymore it was
such a great platform people loved it
right that's cool I didn't love it yeah
so and I think that that is so valuable
the fact that you're able to not only
realize and recognize those those
moments yeah but you're also able to act
upon it you know and maintain the
integrity that you have as a creative
because one of the things that if if
somebody asked me well one of my biggest
fears is one of my biggest fears is
waking up without a purpose
mm-hmm and that scares the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of me because I think when I was
younger I was kind of forced to go
through the motions of things right so
meaning I was told I had to go to school
I had to get A's yeah I had to do this I
had to do that right in order to unlock
this to achieve this thing right right
and if I didn't get that I was
considered a failure yeah right and that
was beat into my head so hard but I
never really followed that [ __ ] path
yeah and I had just had to keep going
through the motions because okay I have
to do this because my parents are
telling me I should do this my friends
are also doing this so I have to just go
through the motions yeah I woke up every
day sad and people didn't see cuz I
always joke about that [ __ ] right and
you know as an I think as a comic you
you always want to you want to crack
jokes about sure I that's why like when
a lot of these stuff that's coming out
on the Internet yeah people see I laugh
at a lot of [ __ ] right I think it's just
like the comic mind that I chose to
develop at a young age yeah yeah but it
was hard man cuz I would wake up every
day going to schools like why the [ __ ]
am I in school man right like what I'm
what am I like well today we're gonna
learn about Tenochtitlan I'm like [ __ ]
that [ __ ] I don't give up man that was a
busy econ major starting off yeah I
could give a [ __ ] less right yeah and I
will wake up every day sad out of my
[ __ ] mind because I knew I had to
wake up and do something that I didn't
want to do and I think that moment is so
scary for me I don't ever want to go
back to that yeah so when I started
feeling
so is Apple so with carpool confessions
when it was doing well but I got tired
of it yeah I started feeling like that
again like dude you're just going
through the motion right now I feel like
the same kid that I was when I was in
college in Sac State UC Riverside you
know doing that same thing waking up
just doing something just because you
were told that yes it just think do it
right yeah and I started feeling that
way about certain things that sure you
know monetarily it's not smart I get
that right right but if I was to live
everyday just chasing a dollar it
wouldn't make me happy yeah and you
wouldn't have been been in your current
situation had you always chase you know
yeah because I'm pretty sure - you could
have stayed in Sweden yeah you know we
mentioned this - he's actually from
Sweden so he's a Chinese Swedish citizen
that came to the United States
right and a lot of his fun a lot of your
influences you know and the person that
you became started off from the music
that you listen to
definitely right which was which was all
pretty much American music yeah which
was like a high commodity at the time
because it was all imported like yeah
like internet didn't exist back in the
day I just sound like I'm half naked
Craig David poster I had what I mean had
bro it's still there talk about I can't
believe you have okay I love Craig David
right I would never have a half-naked
light-skinned black dude on my wall I
stare at him okay what hawk let me say
this we didn't have we had limited
access to which posters we can get our
hands on so he just had a greased up
Craig David Auggie wall had a greased up
Craig David slicker than the average
album original poster not that that
means [ __ ] did he have what was he's
shirtless or did he have like a college
he had a wife beater on he had a wife
and but he was greased up though so I'll
give you that he had the beanie in the
chain he did have the beanie in and I
think he did have the chain the icon
know exactly what that she changed yeah
yeah it's the album cover from his a
second I love Craig David dude dude
that's the law Craig David when I was
when I was trying to come out with me to
that show bro legitimate that I think
we'd be the only males there yeah you're
right we'd be the only pills there and
there would be all the Asian Mary yeah
definitely the only Asian males there
that are there under the age of 40 yeah
oh well yeah you might be right yeah
because I went to a what's it called a
bride
night concert oh [ __ ] yeah and it was so
merry Oh got it for me for Christmas
and I'll put it out there right now any
40 year old 5000 lady that want to
battle me - who knows the most Brightman
night lyrics and songs concert battle
you ain't got [ __ ] on me on this guy
like you ain't got [ __ ] on me I was
there out of Brian midnight concert I
will see every [ __ ] lyric standing up
with my hands out I threw my boxers up
and then she came down at my parachute
dude and it just [ __ ] floated right
down the ride midnight I did that [ __ ]
and then Mario was looking at me she was
like how do you know every [ __ ] song
yeah cuz I love Brian at night yeah I
based my runs off of him yeah I based my
musicality off of him you know
everything I just couldn't sing like him
but I I idolized that guy you know far
off though family far off I you know
what I didn't realize about his voice
well his voice because it's so rich and
deep I only figured this out like a few
years ago yeah was that he's a true like
tenor tenor oh yeah
but his voice is so rich it sounds an
octave lower baritone baritone I'm like
trying to see him how come I can't hit
any of his nose it sounds low yeah it's
not it's just his tone in his voice yeah
he's got a great range that's all he
sounds better live than he does have you
never been to a bribe man never been no
Brian McKnight well I would I would
drink the sweat off his forehead your
heavyset heard his kids sing though oh
yeah one of my favorite albums right now
it is live album I mean the kids are on
there right yeah sons they did a
three-part harmony because she was like
y'see I love that [ __ ] dude oh man I got
it we got to go catch him where's that
salmon well bingo casinos pay well
that's why he's out there probably man
[ __ ] yeah you know I mean for a boy's
two men go out there all the time and
yeah watching boys to bribe and I still
like looks like he got his swag though
yeah you know I mean yeah yeah yeah when
I look at boys to men they they look a
little a little worn out yeah
same on y'all I still love the guys
though man you guys is the [ __ ] you guys
also molded my life a lot oh definit bro
boys to men man you know when I first
got dumped I think that's that's how I
started memorizing all these bright
really
because Brian McKnight and boys - man
yeah all-4-one all these guys started be
going into my rolodex from my heartache
yeah yeah yeah like but it helped Oh a
hundred percent right yo the first time
I ever got dumped
remember I hit up my best friend and
then he took me in his Honda Accord his
burgundy Honda Accord busted ass [ __ ]
lemon yeah we went to a Wendy's I went
into the Wendy's parking lot got
ourselves a double bacon cheeseburger
some chili and some fries and when I
took that first bite I started crying
this was a bro was probably she left me
another bite that cheeseburger oh my god
dude I cried in a parking lot eating a
[ __ ] bacon double cheeseburger my
gosh when I first got dumped listening
to bright midnight music oh man yo let
me ask you this have you ever imagined
like whenever you had like a breakup or
like a big fight that you know your you
had like the drama moment right you're
sitting there and you just imagine them
like running in and say I'm sorry it
sure like that I sometimes I look at
Mariel and I want her to leave me so I
can make dope music I'm Perl dude like I
want to look at Mary oh say hey I just
want to come up to a bill hey [ __ ] yeah
get the [ __ ] out and then I go to you
and gilt let's write this crap dude she
broke my [ __ ] heart yo but honestly
though like sometimes you need I mean
it's terrible but like some July
external stimuli like that like whether
it be for music or anything else like
something that really even for fitness
yeah sometimes like you know it could
motivate you to really just or push you
over the edge of being like indecisive
of what you yeah man I feel music to
like if you're not emotionally connected
or yeah as an artist if you're not
emotionally connected there's no way
that you could really tap into this area
right and I I you know I've been getting
a lot of like messages from people I
haven't talked to in a very long time
yeah and you know that whole crazy rich
Asians things happen
yeah and I want to be an actor I feel
like I could do it yeah listen here you
emotionless [ __ ] like you can't do [ __ ]
not because like well you know it is you
don't have the gift or the talent yeah
and you also and even beyond that you
don't got the work ethic for it right
and that's what it is you're hyped up
because you see somebody else do
something that you want to catch that
way well guess what there's been a lot
of people on that way they just haven't
had the voice for yeah enough so what
makes you think that you're gonna be the
next thing like this dude like I talked
about this [ __ ] man there was this guy
that uh comes up to me messages me and
he goes yo man I saw crazy rich Asians
and you
like yo I want to be the next biggest
action star I was like first of all the
[ __ ] does that mean
yeah alright and I was like okay so what
are you doing to become you know yeah he
goes well I started taking a kickboxing
class okay hold on second yeah go take a
[ __ ] acting class [ __ ] loser right
you know like he he like okay so you are
that missing piece mm-hmm that nobody
has heard about he goes well I feel like
there aren't any Asian American actors
that's doing you know what I'm doing in
the that can do in the action scene and
I'm like what do you mean Jet Li yeah
you mean Jackie Chan yeah life you've
never heard of those people before leave
it's a badlands could Daniel woo what's
his name the Badlands guy oh yes I mean
this is all these [ __ ] you [ __ ]
little Fiat boy isn't that what we're
known for it exactly like the so he
takes a kickboxing class you know and I
gave it to him like what I'm telling you
right now and I'm be open about saying
this cuz I told him this to his [ __ ]
fish you know and I I tell this story
right now I'm not gonna tell his name
out because that's kind of [ __ ] up but
other than that and I hope you're
listening to this again you little
[ __ ] [ __ ] I love you but yeah you
know that it's such a [ __ ] up concept
because I think it's disrespect for the
to those people who have been doing it
right for years and you don't think that
they're trying to get those roles right
right that you think that you're gonna
walk in and take it from them yeah no
you're not gonna do it right it's gonna
take work yeah if you understand the
work that goes behind yeah yeah be my
guest coming to this Roman let's have
that serious calm right and I think that
that's that's the weird conversation I
always have to have and they think I
have this key to unlock it for them yeah
well I mean I think there's nothing
wrong with wanting that right yeah but
you just have to be prepared and you
know realize that it's it's it's more
than meets the eye yeah you know what I
mean sometimes I don't think people well
I don't think they spend enough time to
really think about how much it actually
will cost you yeah people don't like I
even put it like this you know recently
you know Paul Paul and I we put out a
couple of tracks that he did right yeah
we worked on it and vasa he worked on it
you'll have me to let my voice do it
let's just be real with that right so
which are dope by the way y'all should
check them out though they see this
product right there you go give me
another one
would you give me another like you said
I'm a bit like what you mean give me
another one like thank you for the
support but yo this was an original song
this takes time yeah like oh yeah you
know you know I'll be at Paul runs his
own company now right you know he's a
he's working like 60 70 hours a week
right I'm working 60 70 hours a week
yeah and we're still trying to pump out
this music like I wish you know I would
and I'm we're not doing covers right
right this is like original music yeah
you know but even covers take time right
yeah like if you want to really remiss
it it takes time right exactly and I and
one of my goals this year is to stop
putting out things that I don't want to
put out and have it based on people
wanting to see something from me yeah
right
like I want to put out stuff now that I
want to see for myself yeah you know
yeah like this podcast for example this
is something that I want to do right
right right we're having conversations
with real people and a lot of the times
with these podcasts Merkle interview
people who already have a name to
themselves yeah and I think people get
that confused they're like oh well
that's because they have an interest
she's everybody got an interesting story
yeah they just don't have the platform
to speak of Brian we're exactly right
cuz like for you to an idea like your
story is so interesting just because
I've never met a Swedish tiny and you
picked up English [ __ ] fast dude yeah
I was pretty fast but how the [ __ ] did
you do that bro movies and music man did
you know how to speak English before you
came in so we had to take it in like
elementary school it was like you know
mandatory for us to take okay but I mean
you don't have an accent
I don't like what's-his-face Andreas
Andres is it
we love you Andreas yo Andres this
dude's the [ __ ] funniest do to every
man of my life man yo yo let me tell you
this story about Andre oh you got an oh
god that's what I love you Andres I
gotta tell the story though
so andreas came over here and he wanted
to do film and I'm not sure if he's
still doing film but yes he still do we
film but he's decided to go back to
Sweden right you know you don't mind you
when you choose the artists route you're
gonna have some times where you know
you're gonna be a little short on some
cash right
and the dude has a lot of pride as a
human being like he's not looking for
handouts make it and this dude would
choose some of the cheapest [ __ ]
meals but the cheapest meals that he
would choose was [ __ ] even like
homeless people would give him a
dollar dude this dude Adric told us that
he came into his room it was to your
[ __ ] place yeah and this [ __ ]
is eating like steaks is [ __ ]
and this dude Andre has got a plate is
it plateful of cold peas that he popped
open from a can toast and ketchup on it
not even an egg [ __ ] he was like but you
cannot even an egg you could have got
[ __ ] cup ramen dude he had a poverty
meal there people in poverty that eat
better than him I mean I don't think for
andreas defense I don't think it was his
inability to purchase like a higher end
meal that's what I'm saying
just like he didn't have to live like
that yeah yeah he didn't he didn't do
did not have to live like I thought it's
so [ __ ] funny but Andres what the
[ __ ] bro like yo man yeah have a juice
with it right do something for yourself
what nutrition are you getting from gray
piece and this toast would ketchup yeah
you know he's like times what's up yo
it's not that tough Andres right you
[ __ ] eat egg like something get input
poppin egged me that dude was [ __ ]
funny man yeah by me luckily you know he
didn't that wasn't like the majority of
his meals it was his but just walking
into that that's a yeah that was that
was kind of extreme out cheaped all the
Asians he lived with bro that was I I
don't know how that's yeah Andres is one
[ __ ] funny ass dude and hilarious dude
you guys gotta check him out mr. Stoltz
mr. salty that's like sugar reviews
which is so [ __ ] random - yeah cuz I
remember he didn't wear sneakers and all
of a sudden he from what I understand
like you know he always had an interest
for him but never really had really took
that that up until like later on yeah
well recently
so that was tallest [ __ ] tallest [ __ ] he
has like the biggest collection of shoes
man of course because he was a size 18
feet oh yeah that's his [ __ ] his
[ __ ] shoes decides this table nobody
get whatever in stock because there's
only one shoe me right what do you think
the most common shoe size is like a 10 I
came to twelve from from 9 to 11 9 to 11
I say 8 to 11 okay cuz I know 11s are
really hard to get you know and also
nines and tens is like impossible yeah
mine's tens and Elevens are really hard
to bet that the 11 is where I float at
so that that's the sort of anything
north of that
is like using size Elevens - if you try
to get especially the shoe game if
you're trying to get a resell on it yeah
it's always the most expensive expense
eyes 11 is the most [ __ ] expensive
it's either that or like a size 7 some
[ __ ] right yeah and they go out real
fast man crazy I haven't really liked
that many shoes lately though man it's
been a long time since I bought a shoe
we used to buy all the shoes and run a
[ __ ] I sold all most of them anyways did
you really almost for me like I don't
need them anymore like there's no point
bro I wear [ __ ] the checkered vans
you know those are actually comfortable
I wear yeah cuz there's I don't give a
[ __ ] anymore I do but I don't write so I
still got a lot of the shoes that number
one I can't sell anymore because I wore
yeah yeah and we know there's a service
now that you can they'll clean up for
you and so I'll really goat oh go to
clean do it they sell like use shoes now
that's dope yeah but he'll clean it for
you before okay cuz I I checked out a
couple of them and I like go you know go
to has I mean they're not gonna skip out
on you and it's verified yes dope and
they [ __ ] blew up they bought fly
Club they bought flight clay own flight
club net I had no [ __ ] deal they just
came from nowhere bro nowhere right and
just started this online platform for
sneaker reselling what the [ __ ] and then
they bought flight club yo
goat sponsor us yo sponsored the genius
brain podcast you go yeah after I just
told you guys [ __ ] shoes but yeah like I
I think a lot of the resells that I got
yeah I bought on goat just because it
was safe yeah and the prices were
comparable any around definitely yeah
eBay is a little dangerous convenient to
it's super convenient it's always come
shipped super nice arrange that exactly
I love it man yeah like I definitely
yeah man I haven't really bought too
many shoes anymore meant like I the last
shoe that I bought and honestly were the
97 off White's the Virgil house
how'd you get those a fan sold them to
be oh oh didn't sell too cheap you know
a little bit under reso but I wanted
those really bad yeah so you know
yeah I understand me you got to get your
brain oh you know definitely I mean it's
it's worth what it's worth yeah so you
know I [ __ ] with those a lot wasn't nice
those were the last shoes that I really
really enjoyed I got into the [ __ ]
whole Yeezy dad shoe [ __ ] I cannot [ __ ]
with it dude oh yeah yeah those yeah I
know what you mean like it's it's it's
[ __ ] stupid I'm sorry there yeah uh
yeah I'm pretty like yo you could rock
it yeah you could rock anything dude
that's for anybody that looks good can
rock anything that's true but I'm
talking about a shoe that makes someone
like me look good if I wear those shoes
it just looks like I don't speak English
and that's the problem in that's the
problem but you can't put that [ __ ] on a
good-looking dude in a girl and say you
know that's [ __ ] fire yeah course you
could put [ __ ] toilet paper on the
[ __ ] Fisher who's good true if I wear
that [ __ ] Chinese chef yeah yeah Korean
cook whoa yeah okay I see what you mean
you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah they
do different so they do look like I see
what you mean I think the last pair I
got was a period that I got in Shanghai
it's it's a China exclusive model Oh
from Nikes first so they had this new
store in Shanghai that just opened when
we got there it's there like a new
concept that they're doing is like three
or five stories big it's all that dope
[ __ ] I have in there like Hong Kong
Disneyland oh yeah Shanghai as a Disney
low as a Shanghai yeah right but I heard
people just like throw [ __ ] around like
that's that's that that's cultural
that's that Chinese made way bro there's
a bathroom next to him but yeah pee in
the bottle throw in the bush bathroom is
a hole in the ground bathroom
yes agree it sucks because like that's
like a certain part of the population
that's representing all of China yeah it
is not like that no it's not but like
this small little community right it's
like these multi millionaires that are
popping up out of nowhere because of the
land so like I found out from my from
Mario's friend's dad who invested the
property he actually knows how a lot of
these like millionaires are popping up
out of nowhere yeah it's because years
ago and this is what he told me that
years ago they were getting bank loans
to buy land mhm
because whatever that it was they
foresaw that becoming very lucrative
yeah and so they took out a huge loan on
their name bought this land and that
land quadrupled up in price so they sold
they were skimping poorest [ __ ] yeah
because they took this huge loan and
they're paying it off right and I don't
know where that land because people are
buying it up yeah whether to develop to
develop yeah [ __ ] huge so they would
so whatever that they you know hundred
thousand dollars that they're [ __ ]
square
scraping bye-bye because of that low
that their pay yeah became [ __ ] 20
million 30 million jeez so more than
quadruple gajillion more yeah you know
holy so that's where a lot of these like
millionaires are popping up I don't know
how true that is but yeah that's what he
told me in a couple of other people told
me there are some wealthy definitely
have a few friends you know
acquaintances yeah are like pretty
wealthy oh man I see these kids too they
go around Monterey Park that they're
driving around in Jags
oh my god and they don't even know how
to drive bro in college yeah so I went
to USC uh-huh yeah a lot of Chinese kids
like that came from China as opposed to
from Sweden I just want to take their
lunch money bro I want to I want to take
their lunch money and take a roller bag
and beat them God man but even like some
of the apartments that they live in oh
dude dude it's like [ __ ] like
penthouse and downtown high-rises even
like the Vermont remember well [ __ ] yes
all right that was all like the rich
Chinese kids that didn't speak any
English you know and they were balling
out driving their Lambos in there I
forgot who lived in there but when I
came there yeah that was just like
Lambos Ferrari yeah yeah we're there all
right yo what is going on but the
students yep and then that that little
Chinese guy in the supreme back across
his chest came out yeah with the
mismatched clothes mismatched shoes
Balenciaga shoes the Balenciaga shoes
the greasy hair and a little ginseng
coming out of his mouth that goes into
the car drives it backs up into the pole
I'm like son of a [ __ ] dude what is
going on dude yeah man I remember my old
roommate he had a friend in his class he
had a monthly allowance of $35,000 I'm
gonna kill that person bro like how the
[ __ ] that's our pocket money how is that
an allowance I don't know but he would
spend it all how do you spend I don't
even know how to spend $35,000 in a
month I can't do it I physically cannot
do it I don't know what yeah I know it's
like um yeah unless you have like eggs
or bent bills and [ __ ] in the first
month $35,000 and you could buy
everything that I want yeah but monthly
you get twelve at ease in a year dude I
would be that those best friends so
[ __ ] fast and I just robbed them
son of a [ __ ] dude oh yeah was that
even possible I don't know bro he had
three cars from what I understand right
probably yeah yet he listened us he had
a Lambo like you said I'll [ __ ] this kid
is joyride
he had a Benz like [ __ ] s-class I'm a
super high-end [ __ ] right and then he
had a Prius for his every day like why
does it matter what he what are you
saving on gas for with the place when
you have $35,000 a month your [ __ ]
that makes no sense
I don't know man okay so today we have
the Lambo maybe the s-class just in case
I want to be a little down Lee Loki I
want to drive the Prius instead oh yo
hold like how did that even work out
like what the [ __ ] I don't know how that
makes sense bro Tyler I'm so sorry like
I just wanted I don't want to pound out
too hot today like I want somebody to
explain that so I want to be humble yeah
amen I want to hustle hard but be humble
at the same time like I don't understand
that concept dude like what the [ __ ] you
got a Prius bro you're not trying to say
the earth that's a hundred percent sure
definitely not I mean if you're pushing
a Lambo and a [ __ ] s-class what's so
funny because like no matter how much
money somebody's had somebody has it
can't teach you how to pull it off very
well yeah you know and I see that with a
lot of young cats especially some of
these young youtubers like they get all
this money and they just tag up their
whole selves with like supreme and
they're wearing like fur coats it's like
listen bro that may work for LeBron
James yeah that may work for like Damian
Lillard they might you know all these
like you ask you ball star and all these
rappers of [ __ ] right it doesn't work
for you you look like a little [ __ ]
right you know you're walking around
like yo this is Bob nobody gives a [ __ ]
bro yeah rich people are so fascinating
like like a lot of people who have young
money as I call it they got money they
walk up and they want people to know so
hard that they're wearing something
that's worth of value yeah like if you
walk up to them and you don't even
notice they're closed
I feel like they feel bad no letting you
know where that right where's the
recognition
yeah you know where I got this t-shirt
do you know this is my actually do not
[ __ ] your t-shirt yeah you know right
[ __ ] you dude yeah and that's what a lot
of this like this luxury is yeah people
people like to buy and purchase
things I feel anyways to tell somebody
I'm better than you
yeah this is what it look look what I
have yeah I got Gucci this Freddie this
part of that listen to me I got this
[ __ ] on I got the supreme shirt it's a
hundred dollars right [ __ ] what it makes
me look like but what it makes me feel
like is that I'm better than you
yeah either that or like to make
themselves eligible to be a part of some
kind of club some kind of club or quote
unquote the culture
yeah whatever it may be like I think a
lot of times you people need to start
thinking you know feeling better about
themselves you know and and just kind of
accept the fact that they're good enough
as they are yeah and you know what I say
when I say these things to I'm saying
that I kind of I understand because I
wanted to be a part of that close yeah
when I was younger definite uh me too
I'm you guys understand dude like I
bought a Tesla I did all this other [ __ ]
up you know UCS shoes and everything
else and we're not perfect we're not
perfect a hundred percent you know and I
only say this now because like it's I
felt like the small mistakes ours I was
making right people are doing those
mistakes times 10 mmm and it's weird
because I always say this is like the
people without personality always have
to do the most right right so meaning
that they haven't invested in time in
developing lifelong things right
lifelong value right so you have to do
it with things that are fair
compensation to compensate yeah and I I
didn't want to be that person anymore
yeah so yeah look real talk like I I
enjoy nice [ __ ] yeah no enemy doesn't
but if it was taken away from me I
wouldn't die like I don't all my free
time I'm not thinking what can i buy
yeah you know yeah when I go into a
meeting I'm not thinking what can I wear
to make this person think that I'm dope
as [ __ ] yeah exactly you don't say I'm
not like over here stud you know you're
not walking and doing that right and I
think that comes with age though I'm
matured yeah like you know I'll give you
that yeah I feel like I myself I
transcended from like going from me what
do I want mentality to a what brings me
joy mentality best you know what I'm
talking the key dude yeah that's the
[ __ ] key yeah and I feel like
sometimes like even for me
people don't understand why I love my
Honda Element so much
[ __ ] y'all Honda Element haters yeah I
love that car man it was cool pond
elements the [ __ ] I could go in
detail the trunk is dope on the trunk is
dope here's the thing about it I could
go to East LA in my Honda Element and
nobody [ __ ] with me if anything else
people pray for me because I'm in that
car until they come out they bless my
collar water yeah they come up to me
they're like oh my god what happened to
him you know they come up and they bless
me real quick man I love the Honda
Element utility you know something I
don't have to worry about and what
mileage them now don't 87,000 miles
brochure in a Honda Element that she's a
brand new [ __ ] car yeah this is old
people talk Youngblood but I love that
car and I think it's like what I really
like about it too is just something
about utility that I enjoy yeah
like take making the most out of a car
right and I move past this point where I
don't want to spend money on stuff that
doesn't feed into number one my artistry
that's my new year's goal by the way and
the big over escaping I guess the the
huge thing of my new year's goal is feed
your artistry man cuz that's what makes
me happy yeah when I when I started
getting a lot of money right
right now I'm broke as [ __ ] but when I
would have you know I invested money to
a lot of him broke his bus but when I
had a lot of money yeah
and I started investing it into a lot of
stupid [ __ ] right and there was a point
in my life especially when I was bigger
and I was really out of shape yeah and I
just couldn't do physically a lot of
things that I could do yeah i sat on my
ass I went on Amazon I went on goat yeah
I want to eBay and I started buying
things and when these things started
coming in I would open up that package I
was smell the newness I would enjoy it
very much
I would enjoy it for about two days and
then I put it away yeah and then just
stay there and I stayed there right and
touch it right anything with it right
what a waste
okay well I want to feel that happiness
again yeah go back on Amazon look at
some new ship yeah yeah buy it comes in
make it happy yeah two days later it's
gone yeah and I kept doing it over and
over and over and I was trying to fill
something right that this couldn't fill
it's never-ending
it doesn't head right I mean mind you if
you have unlimited money I guess you can
do that but that ends for a lot of
people yeah yo if you meet rich people
they're the [ __ ] weirdest human
beings on earth because they don't know
what to do with their time right people
asked me to they go like this yo David
why do you want to retire so fast if you
retire you'll be bored out
your mind [ __ ] wrong because a lot of
people think that when I retire they're
thinking that I'm retiring my goals in
my dreams right I'm not right when I say
I want to retire I'm talking about
financially yeah I want to retire right
I don't want to worry about me losing
money you're having to suck a dick later
you know I don't want to be sucking a
dick for a taco right what I'm saying is
I want to be comfortable enough where I
could take care of my family everybody
else and then I can choose to make my
job whatever I want to enrich my life
right like not work for the financial
return I could be a pottery yeah yeah I
could make pots for people yeah I could
grow a [ __ ] garden yeah I can learn
Muay Thai do Jiu Jitsu after I'm done
with that I'll learn how to [ __ ] tie
my pubes I've been to a brain and attach
it to the back of my ponytail I don't
give a [ __ ] [ __ ] I like to see that
every [ __ ] cow so when I'm retired
I'll figure that [ __ ] out and I started
to realize with a lot of people they
think that retirement or they only think
about goals as in monetary goals yeah
and it goes back to that right they
think oh well what are you gonna do with
your time if you're retired my career is
in my life right if my career explodes
the next day I'll find something to be
passionate about right
my what I enjoy every day is number one
if y'all don't know I grew up in a
Christian family so for me like I have a
relationship with God
I'll tell you this right now Jesus
blessed his body but Satan takes over
this mouth that's all that but you know
I got my relationship with my religion
yeah I have my relationship with my
friends you know my family health food
and I'm pretty [ __ ] happy yeah
if I didn't have all this like stuff
here right now if it all disappeared
tomorrow as long as my parents are
smiling they're happy and they enjoy
what I'm doing right I have my
girlfriend have my friends I'm pretty
happy yeah you know yeah I think you
know it's it's it's good to have that
perspective cuz I think even when we
were younger trying to come up and stuff
like you lose that a little bit yeah and
it's always like the next come up like
how do we come up you know yeah how do I
gain how do I increase which is
important yeah but you know you got to
have a goal though like like you said
you want to be able to retire
financially yeah I'm not have to worry
about working to be able to support that
lifestyle that you have that's the goal
yeah I think like one of the biggest
eyeopener's that I had was traveling
traveling was so important man it's it's
eye-opening yeah it's it's enriching
mm-hmm and what are the biggest things
that I realized that when I traveled I
took away something that I got to keep
for the rest of my life
mmm um that I didn't get from buying
right quote/unquote dope [ __ ] yeah like
I said I still like dope [ __ ] yeah but
it's not everything to me yeah and when
I would travel I could look back on the
memories and it makes me happy right
yeah I remember when I was in Taiwan and
I went to get Lacroix Bao the the port
yeah yep - it and I could relive that
moment see it in the video see it in the
pictures and yeah you know and I start
feeling happy again yeah I started
feeling that moment again but I never
felt that way when I got a dope [ __ ]
kick and I opened it up and I never went
back to that moment when I opened that
box again and I saw that shoe again yeah
right it doesn't feel the same yeah it
doesn't all for any other thing like
like any electronic device that you
might get like I get a new iPhone every
year yeah [ __ ] my life yeah they have me
by the balls
yeah but that moment when you unwrap it
you know that little cheesy thing
whether you like take off the plastic oh
yeah I love that yeah bro I love that
[ __ ] man it's nice but fast forward an
hour yeah over there [ __ ] oh yeah 100%
you know sometimes you know and this is
so petty I've gone back to return a
phone just to get a new one just for
that moment that moment [ __ ] stupid
that was that was that was a long time
ago but that has happened like even for
me I got that I moved away from the
Apple iOS I went to the second
gratulations thank you the Galaxy Note 9
[ __ ] love the phone right I was
obsessed with that [ __ ] I was playing
with this so much when I first got here
and after a while I it's just the phone
it's just the [ __ ] phone man right
the other day my alarm went off and I
couldn't figure out turnout I just
chucked that [ __ ] in my bathroom
cuz bakka because my bed's next to the
bathroom oh [ __ ] you both there did it
stop oh it stopped okay I think I
stopped it because I probably hit the
button
I don't know why I continued to throw
after it turned off I think I was so mad
at it because I would've shut the [ __ ]
up I just tossed that [ __ ] like [ __ ]
[ __ ] boom you know but that's that's
that's the thing about physical like aab
jaao
therefore momentary happiness is not
what i want to chase any right right
right yeah we go
back to some of these projects I
remember the the track that we did the
ariana grande one yeah still to this day
probably my favorite cover that I've
ever done you know added a lot of
emotion a lot of stayin to it and you
know people [ __ ] with it you got like a
million spins on Spotify which for
somebody who doesn't do music was pretty
[ __ ] well like you're not actively
promoting it yeah I just put it on there
and people people [ __ ] with it yeah they
like this so much yeah and that's the
type of stuff that I want to invest into
you know and I think that's people can
tell like people can tell when you mean
it like when you're creating it like
it's like pooping right yeah you can be
forcing a turd out constipated as hell
yeah that's not gonna be enjoyable for
neither you nor you know I don't know
who else would be watching but whatever
the case is yeah versus like having a
clean a [ __ ] right a hundred percent so
it's the same thing with like any kind
of creative output if you if it doesn't
come from place of love yeah like a
place that you are fully in line with
your creative self yeah it's not gonna
be a good you know it's not gonna have a
good result 100 percent man I try to for
shit's anymore man there you go I'm
trying to come out nice and smooth fiber
baby fiber yeah man it's it's it's good
dude like I feel like 2019 is gonna be a
really good year I always say it every
time but yeah this year kind of started
off [ __ ] for me already but it's it's
it's it's it's gonna be good man feed
your artistry is going to be the biggest
how did you start a [ __ ] like without
having to go in it oh my [ __ ] car
I've got my car fixed but the Honda
Element yeah I still love that car but
that [ __ ] gave me pain dude it's
like a child so I got the thermostat
fixed yeah on it a while ago huh I got
charged for it went back to get
something else that's expensive honey it
was like 500 bucks okay and that was to
go get it fixed again and then now I
started wasn't fine but it was like 300
bucks yeah and then they were like oh it
didn't get changed out as a whole
secondly you guys changed it out yeah it
says here was it I was like well then
why the [ __ ] do I get your last person
that said they changed that they didn't
do it so but they still charge you yeah
they still charge me so yeah we had to
get that whole [ __ ] fixed yeah I was
driving and then Khalif was with me yeah
and then I forgot to put gas in my car
cuz I'm not used to putting gas in my
car
and so that [ __ ] died on me no way right
we had to walk like a mile out
gasps OH daya then that same day I
locked myself out of the house just like
just like when it rains it pours kind of
a situation
bad things happen in threes men there it
is and it really wasn't my week hey but
look yeah at least got it out of the way
so you don't have to deal with that [ __ ]
no more it is what it is man yeah
anyways man uh yeah thanks for coming
through dude of course man what can they
find you any kind of new projects that
you're working in on working in working
in working on well latest one was a
r.kelly cover yeah I know I know I'm
gonna I'm thinking about taking it down
I just wanna take that [ __ ] down okay
being the catching bastard I just
watched the Doc you series and uh yeah
my my life has changed forever change
that's not what is it tight yeah man I
know yeah just you two you know
Instagram Z woods Spotify Spotify B
woods yeah cool
thanks for having me man peace best of
luck